- On The Daily Wire, you
talked about one problem
with our culture is that
we worship celebrities,
but earlier, when you waved to our table,
I'm pretty sure everyone
was about to faint.
(audience laughs)
Do you think that worshiping celebrities
in a conservative setting has almost been
a positive thing for
spurring the movement?
- Well, what I always hope
is the reason that people
like myself is because they like my stuff.
They like how I think and they
like how I express arguments.
None of you know me personally.
For all you know, I
could be an ax murderer.
(audience laughs)
So, when it comes to--I'm not.
But when it comes to celebrity worship,
my problem is not you liking something
somebody says or what they do.
If you wanna be a big Chris
Pratt fan 'cause you think
he's a great actor or you wanna be
and by the way his message to
the MTV Awards was fantastic.
Or if you wanna be a fan
of what he said there,
I think that's great.
What I don't like is when we
start extending the worship
of celebrity into areas where
celebrities have no business being.
I don't care,
I'm glad that Kanye West
said that he's open-minded,
but I frankly do not care
very much about Kanye West's
opinion on politics because I
don't think he knows anything.
And I don't really care
what Kim Kardashian
has to say about pardons for drug dealers
'cause I don't think she knows anything.
If she wants to bring an expert in
to meet the President and talk about it,
that's one thing,
but we have a tendency
in our culture to worship celebrities,
not for the things that they are good at,
which I think is,
I don't like the word worship,
but to like celebrities
or look up to celebrities
for the things that they're
good at, that's fine.
When I was growing up, I was a violinist.
I was a classically trained,
basically concert level violinist
and I used to idolize Jascha Heifetz.
He's the greatest violinist in history
and I didn't idolize him
for his set of personal interactions,
I idolized him because
he's a great violinist.
I think that's totally
normal and totally fine.
I think it's another thing
to say that celebrities
know things that they do not,
so if you're looking to
me for basketball tips,
I would say that that's a waste of time.
If you're looking to me for books to read,
I think that's a pretty
good use of your time.